Крок, удар, нокаут!
Таіссі лише 14, але вона вже може добре захищатися.
Двічі на тиждень вона відвідує курси самозахисту в Берліні.
Для Таісси - це значно більше, ніж просто спорт.
Це дає їй відчуття безпеки.
Мистецтво боротьби завжди здавалося мені вельми цікавим, особливо, коли раніше дивилася фільми.
Але також в реальності це круто.
Тому коли мама запропонувала піти на курси самозахисту, я одразу погодилася.
Таісса тренується разом зі своєю мамою.
Сюди часто приходять жінки, які самі ставали жертвами насилля
і хочуть підготувати своїх доньок до можливих загроз.
Попит на курси самозахисту постійно зростає.
Я сама не раз потрапляла у неприємні ситуації, хоча до фізичного насилля й не доходило, на щастя.
Втім, це було за крок до цього.
Я можу собі дуже добре уявити, як швидко до цього може дійти.
Я знаю це від моїх подруг або знайомих, які зазнавали насилля або опинялися в таких ситуаціях.
Тоді запитуєш себе, як ти сам реагував би, що б вчинив.
Кожна четверта жінка у Німеччині зазнає тілесного чи сексуального насилля від свого партнера.
Це понад 80 відсотків усіх жертв.
Жертвами стають жінки абсолютно всіх соціальних верств.
На курсах самозахисту жінки вчаться не лише давати здачі, але й як запобігати насиллю.
Жінки вчаться спочатку казати "ні" і вміти наполягти на своєму.
Вони вчаться не лише самозахисту, але також запобіганню насилля та деескалації.
Тобто найважливіше - це щоб узагалі не доходило до проявів насилля.
Андрій Шевченко - виходець з України. Він заснував у Берліні школу "Самозахист для кожного".
Тримісячні курси для дорослих коштують 240 євро.
Для підлітків - 140.
Є також спеціальні курси для жінок та дівчат.
Окрім самозахисту, Андрій вивчав психологію у Вільному університеті Берліна.
Тому добре розуміється на психології жертви і нападника.
Ідея курсів вибудувана на трьох підвалинах:
спершу запобігання і деескалація, далі самоствердження, і лише тоді самозахист.
Для Таісси курси самозахисту - чудова розрядка після шкільних занять.
А також підготовка до імовірних конфронтаційних ситуацій.
Зі свого досвіду я знаю, що після курсів почуваєш себе надійніше.
Приміром, коли у школі виникають проблеми з іншими людьми, то вже знаєш:
коли на тебе хтось нападе - ти зможеш сама себе захистити.
Але головна мета курсів самозахисту -
це щоб жінки звільнилися від ролі жертви і до насилля взагалі не доходило.